oh we have guests Jen oh right we have
guests fit
alright we're watching the first time
I've ever seen you here it's your
birthday I'm like Hello
why do you come in in such a Miriam in
such a mood why do you how many your
name on anything yeah gets me in a bad
mood why we invited you on the show I
said of course for once for once you
have invited me on the show it's thank
you very much why I said you went to
men's and maurice i said of course we
want them is anne-marie I feel like
that's the only reason why you're like
Oh Maurice of course absolutely can we
please look you don't need to come in in
such a mood it's Jim's birthday were
celebrating it's a happy time if you're
gonna yell that Netflix special by the
way that's exactly the conversation I
have my stupid manager when's my next
next flick special I don't know
hopefully soon all right this year I
hope 2019 well you know the Miz and
Maurice are now what they're about to be
reality TV what what your own show well
we have our own show but I mean I feel
like I've been a reality star my entire
life no you have but it hasn't said The
Miz on it
right well you know yeah Brewer old Mike
that's true that's true story of seven
strangers picked to live in a house
breath you know I know I remember I saw
the season house Coral doing I don't
know you I haven't talked to her best
friends we were best friends it's a
shame you know you really do lose try
people think that you just stay in touch
with people you know exactly because you
watch people on TV and it's like yeah
I'm sure they're still hanging out just
like that every day nothing changes
nothing
what she died in 2008 no back then you
know we didn't have twitter or instagram
or facebook or myspace was before all of
that Wow
it's almost before the internet I 2001
yeah I mean they did we still grab
herself are offline but this isn't the
[ __ ] speed we're sliced like the only
way I like I'm in any contact with coral
is like through Twitter like sometimes
I'll see her like reply to what am i
retweet something and you're like I
remember that girl yeah yeah she's good
I don't know it's it's icy Twitter
Twitter doesn't really do photos they're
so small yeah you can't
anything can't really see race has no
idea we're talking about because she has
not seen any of my railroad you do I
haven't no you didn't go back and watch
when you guys started dating or VHS
tapes that's all I have of the route cuz
they don't really put them on Netflix or
Hulu right no I don't know where to see
them probably on they're not on DVD I
don't think they are and so they filled
them with like music of the time so all
those rights issues you would never
that's what I've been trying to figure
out why they haven't done that and I
guess that might be the reason but uh
but yeah I mean I have all VHS tapes and
I sent off of greevey so we got I went
out and bought a VHS player uh-huh and
we went to go show it to her and I
watched the first she watched first
episode and just started falling asleep
you know I think you were a little bit
intoxicated you're walking outside yeah
the thing the thing about it was when
you watch yourself
I didn't realize like what I sounded
like would I look like everything so
when I when I watched it I went oh I
don't want her to see this
right you know I just don't like too
embarrassing right yeah it's you're 20
years old you're this dumb kid right you
know living in New York City coming from
Parma Ohio guess what guess what you're
gonna do right your wife met you as an
adult death an expose business already a
man yes you had it you had a foundation
you're not just a kid from Ohio thrown
in front of TV no I had a job right the
whole thing you were doing was the whole
package I'm gonna wash it back then and
so it was great when it was happening
you were to wash that when I'm [ __ ]
good Oh everything has been done like
you've seen everything on TV so it's not
it's what back then everything was it
done 20 years ago there was like three
reality shows and I was on one of them
was season 10 season to him yeah now
there unlike it was like it was there
was real-world Big Brother survivor and
that was it yeah yeah and they were all
huge yeah but you all actually followed
that's why people I'm sure I ask you
about your cast mates because everybody
of that generation followed and watched
every single week because yeah like you
said everything's done now and there's a
reality show on at any point in the day
but back then it was like no this is our
access to watch these strangers it's
survival still big is that popular
showbiz I think it is it's big it's on
network TV yeah gotta be but it's not as
big as
as miz and miz's is about to be before I
know have you seen any of it at all and
they give you any clip good because
that's all not - they don't trust me I
said I said make him watch with everyone
else there's nothing special about Sam
that's what they're exactly what they
said there's attention let me tell you
what happened to me babe
so I had to do a like a day of media and
I saw all these different outlets and I
was going too serious and I go and I was
looking down the whole list and I didn't
see Sam and I was like what why isn't
Sam on here too busy for you and I it
legit they go oh he passed what he
passed now Jim you weren't here I never
passed I did not do you got
misinformation I told you that the last
time you were here you said they get mad
at you for passing you're a lawyer
because I came in here like I told you
no we were talking about iPods
I said say before you came in we were
talking about time that's true it was a
phone topic it was very important but
that's to say I was never even asked if
I wanted the milk or such a lie I didn't
know one of the firt you you you're on
all of our pay-per-view right I would
will not be one of the people that we
come sometimes the first one look
sometimes communication is not its best
you're telling me that you're not good
at communicating not me on the radio
actual right he's not
[Laughter]
Norton and Sam Rob my name still there
it's there but it's yeah not the
headline it's not a minor it's buried
somewhere you did you ask Hahnemann so
what I didn't pass sorry I've never been
interviewed you many many times why
would that be the one time that I passed
I don't know that's what I was trying to
figure out I just don't figure it out
because you're a liar I told you that I
didn't pass okay you know I don't want
to go back and forth again like I
believe you're a liar
you think otherwise by the way you trust
the PR people more than you trust me why
wouldn't I are you kidding I don't lie
would you trust the PR people more than
you trust them 100% because they have no
reason a lie he has reason to lie cause
you're telling him what you meant they
have no reason to lie they have to keep
him happy they have to spend the day
with ya and you don't have
keep me happy and you that's why you get
the lot my past I didn't pass let me go
you love the [ __ ] you want to
interview the miss no past you're doing
a busy dude Tide Pods yeah talk about
the type HUD challenge that's what he
was doing
I remember that Maurice do you believe
how mad he is about this I'm he's bright
it's crazy I was so mad it's crazy he
was shaking babe I was shaking I was so
angry and they were like yeah you know
we got to leave I go no I'm going in
there yeah I can't go in there I barged
in
you thought that I heard you talk to me
yeah I heard about you I call her I go
do you have any idea what Sam did to me
really any idea what he'd Sam did
because I don't think you had other
serious press that day anyway so you
actually came too serious to barge into
the studio 100% regardless of what was
going did not care what you were doing
right well I don't care who's your
favorite celeb you ever interviewed oh
you suck
I guess Maurice he's a big you know I
know gonna guy Hulk Hogan by the way
wasn't the first time I was snubbed by
Sam by both snapped me snubbed me at
WrestleMania wasn't right anybody I'm
not by the way I just watched your
Netflix special and I was looking at and
I saw you guys in the Elimination
Chamber yeah that's the position they
gave you guys at WrestleMania position
on radio row and I was like oh I just
watched Jim's I can talk about that like
how good it was how much I liked it and
then as I was going I was it must be
their grand finale I must be their main
event and as I'm about to go over there
they go oh they're done we were done
waiter they did what do you mean Sam and
Jim are done we're finished
and so I was snubbed and I was like you
that was your timing I could have walked
up it's a whole radio row I had to do I
thought you guys were waiting on me to
do the main to be the main event the
main attractions like wow well nice of
Jim and Sam to make me we had their own
brains that day he wanted Roman reign it
look it's not my call you know I don't
book two wrestlers that's all Sam I
didn't book anybody I just show up and
they'd say give me who you give me okay
so at radio row okay Sam you have no
pool you think I'm more powerful than I
am I guess not huh yeah you give me do
you like that attitude they look at
right well whoever it is yeah
I don't want to see The Miz get the
respect he deserves getting fair yeah I
never get the respect I deserve anything
why don't you think that now it seems
like you are you think I think so now
you have a good spot in WWE you have
your own show coming out I think so I
think you just you just want more right
that's that's that's why I'm so good
maybe you ask for too much do I ask for
two matey
I don't ask for that much is to do is be
interviewed for five minutes that's it
Sam can't even make that for me
hi Brian we talked for way more than
five minutes for five minutes about how
you do not want it do the interview with
him Maurice Maurice you're not supposed
to take Sam Sam Maurice is right you
think this is gonna make us even better
friends if my wife is in there taking
your side just saying in this instance
Maurice is right she is in this instance
Oh in this instance this Maurice I
really appreciate you the person I hate
the most in the world you're sitting
there sticking up for him the most in
the world
yep nobody is right now this moment
yeahbsolutely
I see you and I saw your name on the
schedule in in one way I was like happy
because I wasn't snubbed right another
way I was like now I have to talk to him
right that way every more right check
your calendars what am i doing some I
gotta go to work Sam Sam
love Saturdays so what is your show on I
know a channel on USA tell me that thank
you very much
Tuesday July 24 10 p.m. on USA it's miz
and miz's it's a docu-series basically
documenting what it's like to be
first-time parents in the entertainment
industry and not a reality show I I
don't look at it as a reality show or
unscripted show because I honestly
whenever I hear that word I think fake
and when I always call it a docu-series
because the way I want you to watch this
show is not like oh that was real or
that was not that was this that was I
want you to look at it like you would
watch creepy enthusiasm or the office or
Seinfeld I want you to watch it like a
sitcom I want you to sit back in your
couch release everything that's going on
in your in your in your brain
step out of your reality and enter ours
and just laugh for 30 minutes so it's a
comment okay yeah right
it's just a it's an entertaining shun
comedy unfortunately for ya
it's comedy and I'm the butt of all
jokes okay right yeah that's right oh
you're gonna love it
oh you're gonna love it your show of
course I'm in a lot I support everything
you do smile on your face as soon as I
said that I support everything you do
miss miss miss supportive for a long
time a misfit wow that's cool right for
a long time how old is your baby four
months old oh okay sorry Maurice our
baby's a long time okay especially that
young it is Maurice is right on that Oh
God
it is I mean that's a fraction wise
percentage of its life that's way longer
than two weeks to any of us is there
anything they wanted you guys to do a
look at it doesn't feel right we're
executive producers we do what we want
oh you are oh yeah
so we we kind of that's what we wanted
like when we when I first was told about
the show when would they offered it to
us I was kind of like hesitant because
when I was on the real world you know
going into Hollywood nobody wanted you
it was one of those situations where
when you're on a reality show you're
nothing right no talent you don't have
anything all you do is shoot your life
on a television show you're an oak then
nobody but nowadays you know it's it's
it's okay you can do anything and
everything's a reality show it's it's
Instagram its Twitter it's now
celebrities are trying to get realities
actly it's crazy so now we we looked at
it and said listen if we're executive
producers we have a say in what we can
do and what what's being said but we
also know Maurice and I know that the
things you don't want that we don't want
you to see are the things that you want
to see so we know that going in right so
we went through hell with a lot of it
because a week after she gave birth we
were moving from Los Angeles to Austin
why'd you move to Austin um we just
wanted to change a pace different
different scenery and you know but but
but we moved we had 24 hours to do it
and we had the tour bus my mom so is
that the first episode no that's after
money was born I think the fourth but
Matt Monro my mom two cats two dogs and
a camera crew we were we were drunk
we were talking people are gonna watch
this and think this is this is not real
like the things that happened like we
were
just we wanted to make it the easiest
move possible we got everything done
perfectly right and then everything just
went wrong it was it you couldn't write
this stuff but it's also like for you
for you specifically in that moment I
mean you're not on the road right now
because you just had the kid but you
being on the road like you've only got
two days to pull it all off anyway
because you got to leave again exactly
so whenever anything goes wrong it's
like double wrong
it's Dottie Arabia I actually go to
Saudi Arabia I had to leave my wife who
just had a baby a week ago right and by
the way the moving company never showed
up so we she didn't have half her stuff
so I'm sinner kind of given get stuff on
Amazon
everything is do you have that problem
too
I've never been to Saudi Arabia myself
no I mean the Amazon that the bomb I got
upon boxes every everyday day every day
really every day because guess what if I
need something I can just
Amazon it if I ask my husband it's gonna
take about a week no it's not I when you
ask me to do something it takes five
minutes for me to go to wherever I need
to go to get it for me I mean she's
looking at me it's not true that's not
true but it is true therein lies she
just likes to go on Amazon and just buy
everything yeah that's what for for my
wife it's like she knows that if she
just asked me I'll be like what do we
need that for
yeah wants to skip that stat sure and
just buy there's literally no 100%
packages every day to the point where I
was like we never watch anything on
Amazon Prime like a recycling bin I mean
it's on paper day
oh it's insane it's the word like so my
recycling bin is I need three of them
and not only that but the worst part is
getting the boxes and undoing all the
boxes of course it's hitting me forever
because she'll just go oh and just throw
them in the garage of course and then
guess who has to do it all right me and
then she'll go guess what tomorrow's
recycling day which means for the next
three hours you got a box cutter in the
garage bet shopping everyday you wonder
what the Miz is doing maybe laying out
in the Sun relax I'm chilling out
working on his body making sure
everything is okay for it to go in wh
I'm cutting boxes to put in the
recycling bin from Amazon right so you
go home from this show business
lifestyle you're like I got two days to
relax before I'm back on the road and
you're sitting in the garage
cutting down box well you know I get a
solution for you I'll put you on the
diaper duties I don't mind I'm the
ultimate diaper changer I'm you know
there's no one better than me of
changing down recent you decent
yeah I'm pretty good I'm 2018 converse
two men in 1981 argue this is a very
very cool conversation really is I am a
better help around the house because
because now it's like it's good for men
to be helping out but that il
competitiveness hasn't gone anywhere so
now it's just you just focus it in this
other direction I'm really good at
feeding her singing to her dancing in
everything so we've been talking about
this and Marie's always laughs at the
fact that I don't sing like twinkle
twinkle little star I sing like I'll
remember you by Skid Row or like or like
don't cry by Guns and Roses right here
metal tones can you sing no but Monroe's
guy doesn't know that right and she
loves my voice I remember used a great
song oh yeah yeah so nothing like
Sebastian Bach but that's the thing
about babies they don't know anything
about Sabattus right so I feel like
Sebastian Bach on stage you know in
front of millions but my one audience is
Monroe who's just cheering me on she's
laughing you're literally the best
singer she's ever heard I know why don't
you hear Sebastian Bach and was there
any reluctance to put the kid on TV no I
don't think so
or because your executive producers you
can kind of control we control on what
what gets on and what doesn't
yeah yeah I mean you know it's changing
a baby no not so much right that's right
with like when you now have to go home
and and make your life into a reality
show you have so little personal time as
it is with that a hurdle to jump or were
you just like yeah this is the we move
we just do stuff which is how we're
doing this I mean I was pregnant up to
five days till I gave birth I was
filming Wow
yeah it was you know when I got pregnant
I thought I'm gonna take a two weeks off
I'll go somewhere
yes and someone an island no take a day
off no we don't get days off and we're
very good at jesting to whatever comes
our way
like with WWE being on the road all the
time you're always adjusting your
schedule so it's just another thing to
adjust but now we just have another
human being that's involved and I have a
hard time leaving we I had an 18 day
European tour I came back and Maurice
had Monroe in her hands and I walk in
and I see my daughter and she smiles
when she sees me right oh my god she's
mild yes like that that it melts my
heart like there is a new part of my
heart that has this love that I didn't
even know I had and Monroe has it all
and so whenever I can see her talk to
her I'll be on FaceTime yeah being the
stupidest person in the world like just
knows you do okay you know like and
people look at me like what is this guy
doing in it I don't care right people
are watching me being an idiot to my
daughter because I'm entertaining her
cuz I can't imagine 18 days because with
it was a long time yeah half of her life
cancer that man with kids with kids that
young like when you're gone for a
weekend you come back and they've got
all these new things they've learned
driving but yet it's it's FaceTime is
helpful oh it's it's so helpful just
seeing how she grew like so when I was
came back from the 18 days she got
bigger and burping her I could feel her
face got bigger and I was like oh my
goodness right this is crazy like how
big they get in just a few months when
you met Miz you were a contestant I met
for Mike Mike Mike Mike do you call him
is like two different person no he's my
gonna real life is he really two
different people
mm-hmm thanks Beth what's Mike like Mike
is it romantic okay what you do that's
amazing he's fairly hostile in general
he's totally different
did you bring flowers stuff like that he
does like teddy bears flowers chocolates
but Miz is the Miz so you meant so how
did when you met him because you're both
in wrestling yeah how did he try
make that clear to you because you
probably knew him as The Miz when you're
backed into sometimes back and forth Miz
Mike Miz Mike so you know now I know him
so but yeah you were trying to speak
French to me by the way cannot speak
French we've been together for 12 years
naca and they're trying to teach Monroe
French and I might stop trying to eat
your French so I'm the only one that
does not speak French that's exactly
what's gonna happen
just staring at us talking about me I
could see them talking about me yeah
yeah so yeah so how does he how does he
will you because you know even
especially at that time the Miz was like
I like the cocky attitude I like his
character I like his personality yeah
that's cool
what did the other women think of when
you were like look that's my dude like
what do you what do you think the girls
were like the girls were all jealous oh
my god you have such a catch we've all
tried but you're the only one that got
him no that's what I'm wondering if that
was the response or if it was different
what do you think that what do you think
I have no idea what you have no idea
what's in you a ting very sarcastic like
I always know I wasn't there so I don't
I don't like to hear such a lot you're
so sarcastic girl still good yeah well I
don't like to assume it's the thing
about me I like to go on facts okay go
again that's why I'm asking if like I
actually went to what were the girls
like in the locker where the girls like
name is like really or were they like oh
that's great what were they like
seriously at the time I couldn't barely
speak to each other because I was French
but they were like yeah weird you're
supposed to be like yeah I bet Big Mike
you know and like watching reception
understand me what's wrong with Maryse
you know right and then they were like
yeah what's wrong with Maria they were
like oh how lucky maurice is to be with
them handsome romantic guy he's like the
catch you know we all want to be with
him they didn't say that how did you
pull off getting arrested she's around
every other wrestler it's competitive
like it's nice to be able to do that
where wait are you saying you don't
think the Miz is like a John Cena level
catch is that what you're saying what
I'm saying is when you're my self-esteem
wouldn't allow me when I'm around all
those other guys you met me I have a
pretty good you seem to be very very
confident yeah it's pretty remarkable
actually
my daughter's 10% of him right your
trouble is that we did it with effect
was it his confidence his confidence
when do you like this confidence yeah
because I know a lot of like a lot of
fans and we don't know what's going on
all we know is what's on TV but the
reaction was like what the punk you know
that like that time really yeah
I can't believe Mike is taken like is
that was it was that the reason why I'm
quite not man the mistake you know not
100% that so what was it it was more
like you know we all saw a reason we
were like no way to say no and me means
oh you're telling me I know what yeah
that was kind of for fans I don't know I
just don't know Miz got seriously like
that type of thing later did you hear
them say it I don't remember it was long
that was it you was it you and you're 45
different Twitter account did you see
the Miz oh yeah every Smackdown just he
sucks I don't know why he's he's not
terrible I hate him no that wasn't get
out of here go back to reality but
especially back then when you weren't
the Miz of today you were still
developing a little bit and you know
there was a little bit more criticism
towards you then still is it still is
criticism are you kidding me is that
right oh my god every day but people
like you more now you think so I think
so I don't think so no I think you know
people that love to hate you I think I
think do dad I think that might be right
would they but they react like they're
like they're not like oh I hate them is
they're like booing you like a bad guy
gets booed well they know that I'm at an
elite level and that when I come out
something's going to happen but you
weren't always at an elite level I
always like to consider myself as was
but I think there's a new sort of
confidence that I have right and I think
that began whenever my wife came back
and to have
support like every time you have a
beautiful woman whispering in your ear
how great you are how amazing you are
how incredible you are you know it just
gives you a whole new type of confidence
wouldn't you know I never heard that
stuff
the only whispers the gym hears is why
is it still soft yeah my ear from behind
she's like relax it won't hurt that much
different type of whispering it doesn't
instill the same confidence for each
other for me now I'm already got the MS
I mean what else do you want yeah
did you learn a lot of it like did he
help you learn English a little bit why
I'm still trying to teach her English
really I mean you know and I say I'm
just like you you do not sound like me
you do a lot of a lot of words she gets
wrong and then I'll try to correct her
it's an epidural see I said the same
thing I mean oh no that was different
Missy right on this well thank you yeah
I do it in this this is a epidural
actually getting a bit dural epic yeah
can you do it Jim sure epidural hard
work that's that's that's every day of
my life by the way she'll just say
something I thought about that was wrong
right uh-huh
I don't know you're talking about when
you need a car you know I did that on
she said like a pretty picture I go how
the house what is hooba hooba no hubba
hubba trying to compliment you you look
good yeah and you're like ooh boo you
texted hubba hubba yeah I did think
about it she she since you were like
pretty picture of herself you go hubba
hubba
you know Jim is not a Jim is Jim is in a
different level of
you a pretty picture what do you what do
you girls send you a pretty picture what
do you say is that it the loaded
question a nice compliment do you look
good or waxy depends on with a picture
is right like what type of what would
the picture be I don't know like maybe
in a bikini oh wow you look great your
body looks great it's very sexy never
never hubba hubba motion holy [ __ ] at
least ms sounded like you know like it
was emotional happy boy you sound like
you're just a robot describing what you
see but you're very sexy look very sexy
very nice you want no but you get if you
get a picture somebody they're showing
you their body you tell them how good
they look right I wouldn't do it robotic
way hubba hubba is like saying that if
you do everyone has seen home alone I
knew some people have seen it millions
of times what did you think it was
French what did you think it was when he
said it exactly